because the taxes are tell you
everything about a society and the
arguments as as Steve has so eloquent
eloquently documented in his book they
the arguments about taxes tell us a lot
about our political social and economic
history as well so it he happened to
have chosen the subject that I'm really
passionate about and I loved the book
and I'm sure you're gonna love it too
Steve Weisman editorial for the New York
Times
thank you very much Carla and thank you
all for coming and thank you my friends
for coming and it's I want to just tell
you what an honor it is to be here
because this this place is a wonderful
institution and I've been here many
times in the audience including for my
wife whose book was presented here some
years ago whose books were and so it's a
particularly wonderful fruition for me
to be here
I'm not we didn't really discuss format
so why don't I just tell you a little
bit about how I came to write this book
and what I was trying to do in it and
describe it a little bit and then I'll
be happy to take questions and talk
about it in more detail
one of the hardest experiences of
writing this book I think over the last
few years was to see the expression on
people's faces when night when they said
what are you writing a book about and I
said well I'm writing a book about the
history of the income-tax
and people would say well good luck
Steve that's that certainly sounds
interesting
nobody said oh I love the income tax for
some strange reason so it was a pretty
odd challenge that I set for myself well
why did I do it well I think one of the
reasons is what Karla just said that
although taxes are a distasteful subject
for all of us and something that maybe
we don't like to think about most of the
time in fact we are passionate about the
subject we argue about it incessantly
and not only that our arguments are of
the highest at the highest level of
morality what is fair to the individual
in our society what's fair to our
society itself and I think through the
kind of taxes that have evolved in our
country we see we get a window into what
kind of society we are and want to be
and I don't need to mention of course
since at least 1980 which was the first
presidential election that I covered as
a reporter for the New York Times
taxes have been at the center of all of
our national campaigns and we've been
engaging in that argument for a long
time and and most passionately obviously
with the arrival of Ronald Reagan who
was sort of the poet laureate of of a
certain school of thought and ushered in
a period where we've mostly been talking
about tax cuts although in some years
about tax increases well I I wanted some
of you who know me and others who can
see my background as a political
reporter for most of the time that I've
been a reporter going back to the 1970s
when I was covering the financial
emergency in New York City
New York City almost went into
bankruptcy some of you remember that
I've really been interested in this
subject but and I wanted to write a book
about it
I wanted to write a book about fairness
about justice and about the great
principles at stake in our society and I
have to give credit to my wonderful
editor Alice Mayhew who many of you know
or have heard of who one day I said to
her I really want to write about this
subject in the current era this was in
the mid and late 1990s I think there's a
resurgence of a kind of progressive
impulse about in American society that
really kind of interests me and Alice
said you know I'd be much more
interested in you're looking at the
Progressive Era when these attitudes
first got started and that touched off
an interesting sort of spark with me
because around that time it was in the
mid or late 1990s there were these big
arguments about the flat tax you
remember Steve Forbes and I
simultaneously had curia out of
curiosity just started looking at the
origins of the income tax I didn't know
very much about it but I wanted to
frankly see if there would be some good
quotes to use from some of the people
who originated the tax maybe that could
freshen up some of what I was writing my
editorials and then I saw I delved into
it and I found that associated with the
income tax were characters like William
Jennings Bryan we think of him as the
great commoner the author of the cross
of gold the 1896 presidential candidate
who seized control of the Democratic
Party and transformed it for the next
for really for the next century
I found Oh a character like Cordell Hull
who many of us know as the Secretary of
State during Franklin Roosevelt's period
he was the man
the Japanese visited on December 7th to
announce cutting off relations and they
didn't realize that Pearl Harbor that he
knew that Pearl Harbor had just been
bombed great character in history turns
out he was one of the primary authors of
the income-tax when he was a congressman
from Tennessee back in the early 20th
century back in 1913 1914 the tireless
champion of it and he'd grown up in a
log cabin in Tennessee and rose to a
position of a lot of prominence so I
began looking at the 1890s I love the
1890s I love the turmoil the upheaval
the more I saw the 1890s focused on the
panic of 93 which was the greatest
economic crisis the biggest depression
and economic downturn in American
history until the Great Depression of
the 1930s the panic of 93 was a
remarkable story there were marches on
Washington there were protests they were
unemployed boarding the trains roaming
the country looking for food looking for
jobs
there was an anxiety in the land and out
of this turmoil out of this sense of
protests of the wealthy not paying their
fair share for the government and most
of the revenues for the government being
paid for by tariffs which were
effectively a sales tax of as much as
50% on all the goods that people had to
buy for their livelihood their clothes
their shoes their machinery if they were
farmers this was a just an exciting
period for me it resonated so much with
current history so I plunged in with
that thinking that I would write about
the 1890s and then maybe go up to 1913
when the tax was finally ratified but as
a constitutional amendment this was a
great period of turmoil the tax was
enacted by Congress
it was then overturned by the Supreme
Court as unconstitutional the Supreme
Court then was plunged into a political
fight it was attacked in the country
even Brian himself attacked it people
accused him of having designs on the
court of wanting to pack the court it
was exactly like you know what like the
year 2000 the court was seen as brazenly
political and ideological and
overthrowing the tax then after I
studied the period of the 1890s I did
that thing that I think is alarming to
all editors of all authors when I let my
editor know that I think I didn't want
to start at the 1890s I wanted to go
back to the 1860s I thought that's where
the story really has to begin because
the tax was enacted in the Civil War and
you know editors suddenly get the shakes
and think you know that eventually he's
going to say this has to go back to the
Roman Empire everything or the the Bible
or something which of course there were
taxes and taxes on income forever since
since the times since biblical times but
I instead I went back to the Civil War
and that was one of the greatest
adventures for me I'm by no means a
Civil War buff there maybe even be
people in this room who know lots about
the Civil War and we're all fascinated
and devoted to who the telling and the
retelling of the Civil War but what I I
got this idea that who paid for the
Civil War and it turns out that the
literature on that is not that extensive
but it was there was a huge fight in the
Civil War Lincoln versus the banks the
banks didn't want to lend the money
without some promise of being repaid
they were Patriots their patriotism
wasn't always appreciated at the White
House or at the Treasury Department
but they wanted to be repayed and that
debate that fight about borrowing should
we borrow for the war should the Union
raise taxes for the war and if it raised
his taxes
who are they raised on it was incredible
to me how reminiscent of the debates
that we're having today was the fight
during the Civil War in fact there was
one moment when I was doing the research
on that period where I actually was
interviewing somebody who was then
working for governor george w bush and
he said to me I think that what Clinton
did in the early 90s was immoral to
raise taxes on the rich just because
they're rich is immoral and literally
like a day or two later I was going
through reading the debates in Congress
and Thaddeus Stevens who is better known
as an abolitionist you know one of the
doctrinaire abolitionists but he was
chairman of the House Ways and Means
Committee and his family was owned an
ironworks in Pennsylvania said it is
immoral to raise taxes on the rich just
because they're rich I mean it was
almost word-for-word
what I was hearing today I mean it just
couldn't believe that these debates were
so similar bless you and then finally
after getting through the Civil War
I did not alarm my editor even more and
go back to the Boston Tea Party he or
other taxes or you know the whiskey
rebellion I mean our nation was founded
and in many ways on the concept of a tax
revolt I went I left ahead went from the
1890s up through the Progressive Era
Theodore Roosevelt was the pivotal
figure he's everybody's favorite
president certainly every president's
favorite president he's a great
character he's been written about so
much and yet I found there was something
to to explore there was something I
didn't understand
and about Theodore Roosevelt and his
what was it that gave him this great
antipathy toward great wealth the
malefactors of great wealth I mean he
was a man of considerable wealth he
inherited a pretty good-sized fortune
but it turns out he struggled for much
of his life because although he was a
man of some wealth his tastes were in
excess of those of that wealth and he
was always writing to his wife or rather
his wife was right when he was in the
badlands his wife was writing to him do
you think we could get some money to
turn up the heat at Sagamore and so I
just well I I found it was interesting
to explore his attitudes toward wealth
he proposed the income tax it was
carried off across the finish line er -
that may be the 10-yard line by his
successor William Howard Taft who I was
fascinated by and I'll spare you a
little bit that we can talk about that
later if you want
I wanted to he put it over the top and
with a constitutional amendment in 1909
which he and everybody else in the
Congress thought would never pass why it
takes three-quarters of the state
legislatures to approve a constitutional
amendment and there were that meant at
the time only a dozen states that it
could have blocked it they were what you
won't be surprised the wealthiest states
including New York but the election of
1910 by the time Rosa Teddy Roosevelt
and Taft split open the Republican Party
the Democrats the progressives the
reformers swept into power in 1910 and
to the surprise of everyone they put the
tacks over the top and ratified it
literally finally only weeks before the
inauguration of Woodrow Wilson and it
was then that I realized that I had to
go still one more step in the narrative
and tell the story of World War one I
like the idea of having a book that
begins with the greatest war
that America has ever experienced and
ending it with the Great War World War
one which to my amazement forced another
debate over fairness and wealth and
raised the top rate of the income tax to
77 percent before the war was over we
usually think of that rate is associated
with World War two but of course that
was a very expensive war in terms of
lives lost and the cost of it so that's
the arc of the book that I ended up I
decided to stop there and I felt this 60
years told the period of the great
struggle that laid the foundation for
the tax since World War 1 of course the
tax has fluctuated it went down in the
1920s back up in the 30s and 40s for
world war ii and then down again
starting with john f kennedy who was as
many of you know a tax cutter and then
all the way through the reagan era to
the present day and I feel just too
close that I'd like to think that this
is a timely book because we are headed
into two crises right now we're headed
into a possible war that's going to be
very expensive the White House says a
hundred to two hundred billion dollars
the last Gulf War was paint mostly by
our allies in fact I was living in Japan
at the time of the first Gulf War and
the Japanese had a suspicion that the
Allies you know that the United States
might have even made some money off the
war we don't I don't know
if anyone's looked at the books but
certainly the United States did not have
to pay for that war as its gonna have to
pay for this one and I believe that if
history is any guide I believe our
debates are rooted in history and if
history is any guide we're gonna head
into a sharper debate about wealth and
fairness and will that will force us to
reconsider the Bush tax cuts it'll be a
healthy debate it's the kind of bait we
should have especially at wartime and I
hope that in the by looking at history
in the way I have maybe I can illuminate
some of that anyway so I hope I haven't
gone on too long I'd be very happy to
talk to you and have a conversation
thank you again for listening and I'll
be happy to take any questions you have
friends on c-span can hear us when we
use the mic if you just had that short
question that that will be fine go ahead
I wonder was the IRS the the
organization when it wasn't back in the
Lincoln's time when they must have had a
headquarters that sent out the tax forms
and yeah when was that a staff that was
in Lincoln's time it was the Internal
Revenue Bureau instead of service at the
time it had an office at the Treasury
Department and the first IRS
commissioner was a man named George
Boutwell
who later went on to become Treasury
secretary and I actually ran in the
other ran into the other day a sheldon
cohen who was a former IRS commissioner
we discovered we were the only people we
probably knew who had both read george
bout Welles memoirs
he set up shop they he was a man with a
certain sense of humor they put up a
sign quoting the Gospel of st. Luke you
know that the word went forth from
Caesar that all
that everyone should be taxed and that
was there by word they made up the rules
each evening with a group of individuals
and then sometimes Boutwell would get on
his horse for exercise in the afternoon
or the evening he describes how he went
over to the War Department where Lincoln
would sit hunched over in a shawl
looking at the latest bulletins from the
war and he'd ask him how the war was
going the immediacy of reading that is
it was just amazing yes how did
differences of perceptions of what
government should do affect the people
who were forming tax policy during this
era 1860 to 1920 that's a very good
question someone asked me recently what
was the biggest unintended consequence
of the income tax and I was I thought
about it and I think it is that this was
a tax that was launched and established
to fund war and it ended up of course
funding the welfare state that we know
the great social democracy that we have
but in the period 1860 to 1920 there
were social programs to pay for there
was no Social Security system but after
the Civil War the pension program for
Civil War veterans and their widows and
orphans as Lincoln said care for their
widows and their orphans was huge it was
a big expense so there was a big debate
about that in fact a succession of
presidents got into fights with Congress
over pensions it was like our Social
Security system it was a universal
Vetter
benefit and pension program so that was
one thing that and war and also the
other thing that the tax paid for was
public works projects which were the big
program of the Republicans not the
Democrats the Republicans were the big
spenders and Lincoln believed in it
believed in building canals railroads
roads to connect the country the
Republican Party was founded on the
principle of opening up the less
populated areas with government
intervention and government expenditure
there were other parts of the country
that did not favor that and you see if
you in the debates about the tax in this
period there's something very similar to
the arguments that we're having now if
we raise this tax it'll just go for pork
barrel projects in other parts in the
country spending money getting votes and
that was also an argument that that the
tax generated
yes hey would you compare the relative
success or failure of the North and the
South in raising revenue for the Civil
War yeah the the question was to compare
the success of the North versus the
South and raising revenue for the war
well one of the discoveries that I made
and I did say this to one of my
colleagues who is a Civil War buff is
that if the South had been as fortunate
in its thin and seers as it had been in
its generals it might have been able to
last longer in the Civil War there were
two problems one was that the South was
a decentralized entity after all that
was the cause for which the South fought
to oppose the despotism of Washington so
there was a problem in organizing the
South to raise taxes that was what they
were fighting against secondly the South
opposed tariffs because they were
punished by tariffs the remember the
South exported something like 80% of the
cotton that it produced 70 or 80 percent
overseas it came back in the form of
finished goods clothing and sometimes 50
percent higher than they would have
otherwise paid so they were founded on
opposition to the tariff so that ruled
out the tariff as a way to raise money
what did the South - I think it's famous
they printed money and their money soon
became so worthless that they were
trading in stamps or you know the
counterfeit money their money was
absolutely worthless the North also
printed money finally the North was not
the great success story they printed
greenbacks midway through the
or there was a concern that they that
the greenback's would be held as
unconstitutional but the North struggled
through in part because of the income
tax and although there the ratio in the
north was on health in an unhealthy way
more toward borrowing than taxes and
provided an example that for the rest of
the century and into the 20th then
everyone did not want to repeat their
they were more successful in raising
revenues from tariffs and taxes and
ended up very quickly in the late 1860's
and into the 1870s in the Union was in
good shape and running up surpluses yes
I have a question and it's because I
don't understand how it works I guess
but this bit of income tax okay there's
a certain percentage go to the state
when it's collected from the state and
the rest go into a common pot for the
whole United States and who decides what
part of the common pot in the United
States goes for other countries and one
more part of this question I don't mind
helping people but I'm pretty tired of
having it taken from my pocket always
not being able to do anything about it
why can't we send people overseas to
teach the people in the other countries
how to raise their own money and take
care of themselves now that I really
sound very adamant and well anyway
that's okay you get the message it's a
subject that we have strong views about
first of all just to answer the first
question back in the war of 1812 and in
the first part of the history of the
country when there was a crisis the
federal government did in fact raise
taxes simply by saying to the states you
give us you raise the tax any way you
want and send it to Washington but
that was a very inefficient system it
led to unfairness different states
raising them in in different ways
actually the the South tried to do that
during the Civil War they would assign
an amount of revenue to the states they
knew they shouldn't borrow well guess
what the states then just went and
borrowed it and sent it to Richmond in
that case so the federal income tax that
was enacted was a tax all of which was
collected for the federal government
now tax paying overseas I guess that
would be another book you know my wife
and I have lived in Asia and we lived in
India for four three and a half years
that's a country of a very poor country
but there's a lot of wealth in India
especially now but even going back to
the days of the Maharajah's and boy
Indians just they don't they don't pay
taxes it's like what you read about the
Russians you may I think maybe some of
you saw the story about how the Russians
adopted the income tax it was a flat I
think it was a flat rate
it wasn't progressive but and it wasn't
a very high rate but it was a real step
forward because although it wasn't a
high rate the idea was to get people
used to paying taxes but in places like
Russia or India or a lot of countries
that are poor but have wealth what
people do is they shelter their wealth
overseas in bank accounts abroad that
even happens in Israel and other
countries I guess it happens in the
United States too and it's it's very
hard for us to you know inculcate that
taxpaying spirit into other countries I
guess we have enough trouble persuading
our own people to pay taxes
Japan while you were talking because I
was gonna ask you about that
well Japanese tax rates are very high I
don't think there is the level of
evasion in Japan there that there is
yeah I think the Japanese are are very
good about paying their taxes and maybe
somebody in here can correct me on that
but the Japanese society is a much more
intrusive society into your private
affairs and private bank accounts and
they keep track of it and attacks taxes
are very high there the Japanese however
are also running probably one of the
highest budget deficits in the history
of government right now and but that's
for economic reasons not because I mean
they're trying to stimulate the economy
and not because people are evading taxes
yes sir yes I was hoping you could talk
about the techniques and opportunities
that Americans had during the time that
you studied for tax evasion and tax
avoidance and presumably there was no
Switzerland or Cayman Islands to to run
- yeah well that's a very interesting
question you know after the tax was
enacted Mark Twain filed something like
$36 tax and he wrote a letter to the IRS
saying that he was really proud he
finally felt he was proud to be
recognized by the federal government and
it made him feel important I don't think
that was a typical ad but the extensive
evasion evasion was a it has probably
grew to be a problem much later in the
history of the tax especially when
loopholes started open opening up in the
more recent decades but you know one of
my favorite moments
in this period is the debate in 1894
over the enactment of the income tax and
evasion was a key part of that debate
because opponents of the tax argued we
can't raise this tax because it'll just
be evaded people will cheat or people
and if they don't cheat it will require
an intrusive government to come in and
look at their books that was appalling
to Americans in the 19th century and
there was a prediction by some that
people would go overseas and evade it
and going that the wealthiest Americans
would just evade the tax by moving
overseas and Brian you got to read his
speech it's just great you know he gets
up there and he says he turns to all the
congressmen they said oh I see you're
worried about cheats you know well you
must be talking about your own
constituents if you know them so well I
mean it was a master rhetorician and
then he said and he had done his
research he was a prodigious self-taught
person who did not like to go to social
events in Washington he loved to spend
his time in the library the Library of
Congress studying history and he ordered
the State Department to do research on
taxes in all the countries of Europe and
he said well I guess you're afraid that
taxpayers will go to Europe well that's
very interesting he said now let's see
where would they go you know and then he
started listing all these countries well
will they go to England well maybe
they'll find that the income tax there
is already higher than this one that
you're proposing and maybe they'll move
to Prussia and maybe they'll move to
Scandinavia and he went through all the
countries that everybody said they would
move to and he just demolished the
argument and then
ended with the with quoting from the man
without the country country about those
who would you know move abroad just to
evade a two percent taxes their
patriotism really only two percent deep
is that the kind of country he want we
want so I'm not sure the answered your
question about the extent of evasion if
there's always been tax evasion it's
always been a problem that people have
wrestled with in ways very similar to
the way we're talking about it now with
corporations moving to the Cayman
Islands or whatever and but the real
problem of tax evasion comes a bit later
yes young man the book covers six
decades what was the most challenging
thing the most challenging part of
writing the book and what was the most
fun well not surprisingly that's a hard
question I think the most challenging
thing of writing narrative history in a
book like this is when to step back and
give background and explain when you're
introducing a new character you suddenly
have to go back in time and when you're
writing you have to constantly be aware
of keeping the narrative going and not
interrupting every time you introduce a
new character and yet that was very hard
for me because my curiosity you know
went would fan out every time I found
somebody interesting like Thomas Sherman
who was a big corporate litigator in New
York oh he's an interesting character
why did he know so much about wealth and
then I began studying the history of the
law firm of Sherman and Sterling and
then actually they helped me and they
said oh well you went to Yale which is
where I went as an undergraduate
sterling Sherman's law partner endowed
the Yale Law School and all this
during professor's there and I thought
oh gee this is not interesting you know
well you just you have to get yourself
you have to control yourself when you
when you're doing a book like that so I
think that's the hardest part of writing
it and the most fun part it's a nice
question I think is just you know I'm a
political reporter by trade I've covered
politics all of my career for the New
York Times I've had a great experience
and it's been a great adventure for me I
think the fun of it was looking at
history and writing about it as if I
were a political reporter and trying to
provide the context but capture the
personalities and capturing the issues
and the intertwining of them capture
that debate I was talking about before
with Brian and his opponent who was one
of the Democratic bosses in the house
and you know excuse me just following
the you know the the 1909-1910 election
campaign which is not a campaign that
many people care about or know about
just the little moments like when
William Howard Taft was campaigning and
he was presented with a bathtub and he
he enjoyed getting the president until
he found out that the people in the
Midwestern town that gave him the
bathtub wanted him to take a bath in
front of them
he weighed 300 pounds they they thought
that month must be something fun to see
so it really I think the most fun was
seeing how alive politics were and
trying to recapture that and write about
it as if you know just as the political
reporter I am 3/4 of the states required
to approve the constitutional amendment
can you illustrate further some of the
states that did not approve of the
amendment
yes let me talk for a second about the
one state that initially did not approve
it and then change then that was New
York because New York was pretty typical
during the Civil War I can't remember
the figures exactly but something New
York paid something like 25 or 30
percent of the entire federal income tax
with only a small much smaller
percentage of the population so not only
the Republicans but the Democrats
everybody in New York was against the
tax and once New York voted against it
everyone thought that the tax was dead
and they affected a lot of the other
states including the wealthy states
which then were New Jersey Connecticut
Rhode Island New England to some degree
in Massachusetts remember these were
that what these were the states in the
19th century that wealth were factory
that that were the heart of American
industry
it was the agriculture states and the
far western and the and the ranching
states and the rural states that were in
favor of the income tax because it was a
tax on the wealthy states and so when
New York switched in the great election
of 1910 I keep coming back to that don't
I and elected it was a true tremendously
interesting election to me the more
there was a more interesting election in
New Jersey in 1910 a new governor there
named Woodrow Wilson same situation that
flipped New Jersey over to the yes
column and and in New York as well the
holdout States one of the one of them
for instance was Rhode Island and I
think in Pennsylvania was a holdout they
were remember back then the legislators
were both gerrymandered and they still
had this was before the Supreme Court
decision in the 1960s of one person one
vote
so legislators
tended to be dominated by their own
rural interests and they in turn were
dominated by political bosses and
political bosses were in turn in many
cases in bed with the wealthy interests
in the state from whom they got money
so Rhode Island was a lot of rotten
boroughs there and you know those are
legislative districts that hardly have
anybody living in them but we're still
represented they were they continued to
vote against ratification yes have you
found that the the antipathy against
versus the understanding for paying
taxes has remained pretty constant over
time or has it changed over time I have
to be in particular periods that people
were more understanding versus less
understanding yeah well you know Woodrow
Wilson said that paying taxes was a
glorious privilege I don't think that
that was typical of most Americans at
any time but obviously war time makes
Americans more willing to pay taxes and
it also makes Americans more willing to
lend money to the government the big
bond sales of the Civil War Jake hook
you know we're successful and in World
War one the Liberty Bonds but on the tax
side people are willing to accept as a
matter of sacrifice paying taxes so I
think that's the short answer but the
other thing is that Wars tend to
accelerate or accentuate the basic
arguments that we have in our society
over fairness and wealth you know we
have been through a period of the 1990s
obviously where Americans celebrated
wealth and saw the great and I believe
this is a constant impulse in American
society to see to admire people who are
wealthy because wealth represents I
believe to most Americans to some degree
a reward for good behavior as Ronald
Reagan would say saving investing
working hard taking risks you hear
George Bush talk about that we shouldn't
punish people who do these good things
by taxing them disproportionately and
that's an impulse that always has
existed in America going back to the
Civil War contrary to this is the sense
that we need to keep society together we
need to have a sense of fairness you
know at the Civil War during the Civil
War if on the Union side for most of the
war you could pay $300 and get out of
the draft and there was a moment in the
Civil War where the Treasury Secretary
salmon chase his daughter was getting
married in Washington it was a big
society of it
everybody attended except for mrs.
Lincoln who resented the this young and
beautiful daughter and salmon Chase
bought his daughter a $3,000 shawl at a
department store in New York Stewart's
department store which along with Brooks
Brothers was one of the big department
stores at the time and you know that was
the cost of ten wives people in wartime
especially are acutely aware to these
inequities they that that was the kind
of consideration that led to not only an
income tax but a progressive income tax
that was higher on those who were
wealthy Thanks
I have a was had recently listened to
founding brothers by Joseph Ellis and
was overwhelming overwhelmingly struck
by the how the the fights the the the
disagreements that have persisted
throughout our history and Ellis does a
very good job of in a very economical
way showing you how these the founding
brothers face some of the same issues
that we would be facing years hence and
I think Steve does exactly the same
thing in this book by focusing on the
decades from the Civil War to the first
through the First World War he is able
to illustrate the the debates that took
place then that we would be having in
the 40s and in the 80s and 90s and and
that we're facing all over again right
at this time and it's a real tribute to
to Steve's book that it received a
wonderful review by somebody who I dare
say is a lot more conservative then
Steve is yesterday in The New York Times
a great a review by Bob Samuelson which
pointed out what a fair-minded and and
and fun to read book it is which it is
so um thank you very much Steve and
congratulations to you and the books are
for sale in the front of the store and
you're watching book TV 48 hours of
nonfiction books coming up at midnight
Eastern a look at the influence of
Wahhabi Islam and its ties to the Saudi
royal family with Stephen Schwartz
author of the two faces of Islam then
meditations of Marcus Aurelius with
translator Gregory Hays Sunday night
Robert Remini profiles Mormon Church
founder Joseph Smith after that on
public lives a panel featuring
biographers Robert Kira